you're serious aren't you you're telling
us you killed those three young men on
the subway
and why should we believe you ain't got
nothing left to lose
not everybody does this it's extremely
rare and in fact
the joker unfortunately overplays the
idea that mental illness and violence
are linked
hey gq i'm dr eric bender i'm a child
adolescent adult and forensic
psychiatrist and this is the breakdown
first up bojack horseman okay
trey and i will be in the coke room
doing hand stuff otherwise
you don't know anybody here hollyhawk
has walked into this party and her
friend is teasing her right away you
don't know anyone
that is the worst thing you could say to
somebody who has what's called social
anxiety disorder
in social anxiety disorder people are
terrified that when they go into a
setting where they don't know people
or even when they do know people that
they're going to embarrass themselves
that people are going to
see that they're anxious they might get
so upset they might even have some
bodily pains like nausea or stomach
pain and they want to avoid the
situation
as she looks around she starts to get
more anxious you see her starting to
hyperventilate she's starting to get
short of breath
they're all kinds of anxieties and they
differ in very significant ways
sometimes anxiety is really serious and
we call things disorders if in fact the
anxiety
impairs people's functionings during the
day or in these cases
say if she does have social anxiety
disorder she avoids socializing
that's pretty important for development
that's impairing part of her life in a
part of her day
if it's a certain situation people avoid
that can be called a phobia like a fear
of snakes
fear of flying so there are specific
situations that arise
that cause people anxiety too oh
what do you see what you're having an
anxiety attack so look around the room
and tell me what you see
i i see people partying
and passing out this guy has done a
really good job here of using a therapy
technique called
grounding i have used this with patients
when they get super anxious
you can tell them to look around
themselves and to tell themselves where
they are
i'm standing here i'm in a room it is
tuesday
what else do you see um books pizza
boxes
i see light fixtures i see
an odd amount of four poofs that's a
terrific technique he also calls it an
anxiety attack
that is another word people use to
describe a panic attack she's clearly
having a panic attack here
he helps her with this grounding
technique you feel any calmer
yeah actually it's a trick my
psychiatrist taught me
i'm peter by the way so this party's
kind of crowded
you want to go get some air yeah if
there are a lot of people around you
blocking where you are and where you're
breathing yeah absolutely get out of the
room and get some fresh air you hear
fresh air because a lot of people have
trouble they're
they're trying to breathe so you want to
get them out to a place where they feel
like they have more access to air
so that can be more psychologically
helpful too but i think sometimes it's
even more
all right let me get out of this crowded
environment that's making me feel like i
can't breathe
the panic attack usually comes on sudden
onset and they can tell they're having
one
they might say yeah i suspect if i go
into that situation i'm gonna have a
panic attack
but when it happens it's just a super
sudden onset
for most people sometimes people with
anxiety tend to drink
more use substances more they want to
feel relaxed
alcohol can relax you to some degree
however
it can also on the rebound make people's
moods feel worse or make anxiety worse
so then you can run into bad cycles of
people feeling good
and then it wears off they take more and
they take more so there's this feeling
like you can help
but in the long run it might be hurting
more i can't believe that one of the
best
portrayals of anxiety and getting help
comes from a cartoon about
anthropomorphized animals but this is
really great
first off this guy's saying hey i go to
a psychiatrist that's going to make
hollyhock feel better
he's saying try this it's helped me
that's going to make her feel better so
this is a really good portrayal next up
joker you're serious aren't you you're
telling us you killed those three young
men on the subway
and why should we believe you ain't got
nothing left to lose
so i think about a couple of things the
first thing is psychopathy and
psychopathy is not a mental illness
it's not a diagnosis psychopathy is a
collection of personality traits
and that includes feeling no remorse it
includes being callous
uncaring the joker here is letting us
know he's exactly that he has no remorse
for killing these three people
he also says he has nothing left to lose
in a violence risk assessment in
forensic psychiatry you look
for things that are warning signs such
as
people who have been isolated and lonely
people who have felt traumatized and
persecuted
and those who don't have any resilience
factors factors inside that help them
recover from traumatic events or
external support and that's
exactly arthur fleck that's the joker
that can be what's called a pathway to
violence
not everybody does this it's extremely
rare and in fact
the joker unfortunately overplays the
idea that mental illness
and violence are linked it's important
to know that we don't know
why people get pushed over the edge and
there are very very few so that's really
important
at the same time there are people who
are repeatedly traumatized neglected
abused and there's a rage that can
develop
inside them and i see that sometimes in
psychotherapy when i'm talking to people
who've been chronically abused or
traumatized
but again those people do not for the
most part go out and commit any violent
acts my life is nothing but a comedy
let me get this straight you think that
killing those guys is funny
i do and i'm tired of pretending it's
not
there's a difference between psychopathy
and psychosis
psychosis is a break from reality people
are hearing things
seeing things it's called hallucinations
those are psychotic
issues the joker doesn't seem to have
any of that
in cases of psychopathy people use
others in
their lives to get what they want other
people are pawns oh
why is everybody so upset about these
guys
if it was me dying on the sidewalk you'd
walk right over me
we see his mood go back and forth from
irritable
to seemingly crying to almost laughing a
little bit
that can be called a couple different
things one word is lability where you
have such
shifts but what explains it even more is
probably a diagnosis of what's called
pseudobulbar affect and what that means
is
there's a disconnection between the
front of the brain the cortex and the
back of the brain the cerebellum
that connection actually helps us
express our emotions
when that's broken either because of
trauma and we know arthur flack has a
history of trauma to his head even that
connection can get disrupted and what
happens is there can be a sudden
onset of crying or laughing
even though the person might not even
feel as if something's humorous or that
they're sad it just starts
what do you get i don't think so when
you cross a mentally
something that also shows that this is
more of what's called psychopathy and
not a psychosis a break from reality is
that he's telling murray exactly what's
going to happen this is what you get he
knows clearly what he's doing that shows
he's of a sound mind
he does not have any psychotic issue at
this time he's not
hearing voices he's not seeing things he
doesn't have delusions
in fact his complaint about feeling
discarded that is a common feeling among
people who do
try to seek help in the system for the
traumas they've experienced
psychopath you hear that word and you do
think of a serial killer because a lot
of the serial killers show
psychopathy they don't care people are
just pawns in their lives they're there
for entertainment
and i think in the joker's case you
might look at him and say here's this
dude dressed all and clown makeup
there's got to be something wrong with
him
well he's actually trying to be noticed
in some ways this guy's lacked attention
for his entire life
and he's been neglected he ends up
getting pushed over the edge and again
we don't know why that happens and
he turns to violence there is a genetic
component to mental illness and his
mother did have severe depression
it's also much more common that people
realize one in five americans will have
a mental health challenge within a year
and in fact
half of americans will have some mental
health issue during their lifetime
while the joker ends up portraying this
link between violence and mental health
issues that doesn't exist
or it perpetuates that stereotype it
does do a very good job of showing that
resources can get pulled at any time at
the end of the movie the social worker
is explaining that nobody cares about
people like him
that in fact money goes away and that
does happen a lot
so clinics might be there and then
they're relying on funding that suddenly
gets pulled
and that translates into less help for
people who really do need it
next up rain man sally gibbs dipped
sally
461 00192
how did you know my phone number how'd
you know that you said read the
telephone book last night tip sally
okay so this is something it's pretty
rare it's called savant syndrome first
off
the idea of someone being able to read a
phone book and memorize it and know
phone numbers that is a pretty
extraordinary ability
right now they're supposedly maybe one
in a million people living with savant
syndrome that means there's a certain
gift and it's usually in a few areas it
could be an
art in arithmetic or math it could be in
music
so here we see raymond is able to
memorize phone numbers he has this
savant syndrome
he also has autism autism is a
developmental disorder which means that
as someone is developing
they don't develop in the way most
people in society would develop and in
autism you look at two main areas you
look at how somebody's developing and
how they're communicating and that
includes do they
make eye contact and communicate with
language do they actually
seek out reciprocity or do they offer
reciprocity meaning can they participate
with someone in a conversation in a
normal way
or do they not point things out not try
to draw attention
to things in their world and not respond
to people and you look and see
how they respond to non-verbal cues
non-verbal language people with autism
can have some deficits in some of those
areas
another area you look at is the
interests of people with
autism where someone maybe just hones in
on one thing
and sticks with that and has an unusual
attachment to that one thing
or do they have a broad range of
interests also you look to see if
somebody has what's called stereotyped
behaviors it's an attempt to really
soothe oneself but it doesn't really fit
we see a little bit of self-soothing
here in rain man where raymond at first
is rocking back and forth like this he's
trying to calm himself down
so these are things that i look for in
autistic spectrum disorders
it's also important to note autistic
spectrum disorder or autism
it's a wide spectrum just like if you
say you're sick
you might have a cold or you might be in
the icu and need surgery
if someone has autism they could be
impaired severely
and raymond is more towards that end or
someone can be highly functioning and
have what used to be called asperger's
disorder where they don't really have
the
problem of never developing language
which can happen in severe cases of
autism they might develop
language but there are these other
quirks about them
chris i don't have my toothpicks no you
don't need toothpicks i don't want my
toothpick you don't need toothpicks for
anything
pancakes keep sliding off you're gonna
eat with a fork i don't have my maple
syrup either i'm gonna be without my
maple syrup
and my toothpicks here we see what's
called an adherence to a routine that
doesn't make sense to most
people but to someone with autism like
raymond that routine really is important
and you can see
his brother just wants to get breakfast
he just wants to eat but
when there's a shift from that routine
it can be very hard for someone with
autism to deal with that
in terms of why a lot of people believe
it is a comfort it's a soothing thing
and when he's pulled away from that he
has some trouble
definitely definitely not gonna not
gonna have my my pancakes
so tom cruise well he seems to be a
jerky guy
in the movie in some ways he's
responding to raymond at least in this
scene
the same way most people would feel
frustrated
i see this with families sometimes with
children with autism for instance or
even adults
they just want to eat breakfast they
don't want to go through this routine of
like putting things out in a certain way
so a lot of times families will say to
me do we do this do we just
go with these routines or what there is
a method of teaching
people with autism to discover and
to work on behaviors that are not
adherent to their routine
applied behavioral analysis is the
technique
and you are really positively
reinforcing behaviors
that help someone deal with shifts in
their routine you reward that
and that teaches them that they can
actually do something outside of their
routine they want
there are times when you do feel forced
to go along with this adherence to
routine
but there are ways to change that
a2 82 a2
it's a lot more nade two to three plus
246 total change what also is seen here
is more of this savant syndrome
about half the people with savant
syndrome have autism the other half have
other
abnormalities in their brain development
in fact the person
kim peak whom supposedly raymond babbitt
was based on
he actually had a different type of
issue with his brain
not related to autism but again savant
syndrome is very rare
rayman does a wonderful job of bringing
to the screen a topic that was not
talked about at all
this was great it started a conversation
the challenge here is that rayman ends
up making people
think that if you have autism you have
some superpower and that's
not the case next up the undoing
the defendant's mother told you that
jonathan suffered neither guilt nor
grief
in reaction to his four-year-old
sister's death
they were certain once the shock wore
off the suffering would begin but it
didn't it never came
there's a difference in my mind between
suffering and remorse
not being able to suffer to me doesn't
suggest that someone doesn't
care some people really push away those
feelings they don't let themselves feel
sad about it
just because somebody doesn't grieve the
way we would expect doesn't make them a
psychopath
but the lack of remorse seen again and
again and again and again
that could make somebody a psychopath if
i'm looking at a lack of remorse i'm
looking for other
qualities about somebody too a
collection of personality traits to say
they're psychopathic so that might mean
somebody lies consistently about their
background and who they are
where they are what they're doing
somebody is
very glib able to feign interest in
things
i don't look for just no grief and no
remorse i'm looking for this collection
of things together
you told your friend sylvia steinitz
that you believed your husband suffered
from narcissistic personality disorder
wasn't a professional diagnosis but your
opinion
narcissistic personality disorder is
another type of personality disorder
a narcissist they do have a sense of
grandiosity a sense of self-importance
there might be
fantasies about unlimited power beauty
money things like that there are a
number of other
ways someone can be a narcissist but
there's a term called malignant
narcissism which is used to describe
people who do have the narcissistic
personality disorder
that include this lack of empathy that
include using people in exploitative
ways
in fact when we look at serial killers
sometimes we say that serial killers
have malignant narcissism that there's
this lack of empathy and again these are
psychopathic traits
as well psychopathy is really
interesting because even in populations
that are very
genetically isolated you might get a
psychopath
popping up just they're born that way
that's the idea that
innately there's just this callous
uncaring nature to them
the old way of looking at psychopathy
they had what were called factor one
traits
there were traits about your personality
and they had factor two traits that was
the criminal behavior
so there's different layers of criminal
behavior and doesn't have to be murder
some people think that there's
white-collar psychopaths so to speak
where in
companies people are doing things that
are kind of dodgy not exactly following
the rules
and maybe those are psychopaths too
there was a book a couple years ago
exploring how
many ceos might have psychopathic traits
perhaps there's something about power
perhaps
in order to get to that level you have
to not care about other people you have
to
demand a certain level of treatment and
respect and that's what narcissists do
so there are all these different factors
of narcissism but like i said it doesn't
mean they all lack empathy however
perhaps there's some degree of that in
certain people that do make it into
those positions
doctor in your practice do you not tell
patients that
sometimes they so want to believe in
their partners that they
they choose to unknow things and see
things there are cases of serial killers
where their partners had no idea that
they were out there killing hundreds of
people
that's pretty common that people don't
know about that side of their partner
i think as a psychologist or as a
psychiatrist you might actually
try to hone in more on people's
personalities but you know separate
business and pleasure so maybe there was
a lack of ability for her to see that
it wouldn't surprise me next up as good
as it gets
i think what this character is certainly
trying to depict is something called
obsessive-compulsive disorder or ocd
now obsessive-compulsive disorder means
that an individual has obsessions or
intrusive thoughts that don't feel right
to them they feel what's called ego
dystonic it doesn't mesh with how they
actually
think or believe or feel but something
so powerful about them that they obsess
over them
and then what we saw here is what's
called compulsive behavior
the compulsions are the behaviors you do
to get rid of that anxiety over the
obsessions
it's a pretty extreme example jack
nicholson's character has
the obsessions over being dirty and the
obsessions over numbers and the
obsessions over this
i mean that's a pretty extreme example
but that's what hollywood does to try to
depict
these things what's not seen is just
how powerful the obsession itself can be
you kind of glean that from the fact
that he's doing all these things
that that obsession about being dirty is
so upsetting to him but that part's left
out it can be an extremely uncomfortable
feeling not to
participate in the compulsive behavior
his anxiety level might be
sky high and that's why he's doing this
to avoid that feeling
so he's driven to do it to get rid of
that severe severe anxiety there are
ways to treat this there's
cognitive behavioral therapy it's a way
of challenging your thoughts the
cognitive part
even more specifically is something
called exposure response prevention
you expose yourself to the thing that
makes you so anxious
so if it's that he's going to be dirty
you might have him touch something
that's dirty
and then wait not wash his hands
immediately and the idea is with
repeated exposures
he could actually have his anxiety level
go down over time
we don't know why it happens it does
just come in and start
and you really do need to treat it with
exposure and response prevention
and also some medications people can
actually have rituals or routines that
they do that seem very obsessive but
never really get diagnosed
so for instance if you're always worried
about the door being locked
and say you live with somebody who
doesn't always keep it locked and you go
back and check
that serves a functional purpose that
means there's a reason you do that
making sure you're safe but at the same
time for some people there might be an
element
of an obsession about that a fear that
somebody's going to break in a fear that
the door is not locked
so you can have ocd symptoms and not get
diagnosed
hi help
if you want to see me you will not do
this you'll make an appointment
so here we do start to see just how
upset jack nicholson's character is with
these anxieties and these obsessions
these compulsions that he has
if someone has ocd they're not
necessarily going to be a jerk and act
this way
the psychiatrist responds well by
putting limits on things and boundaries
we're not going to do this now
if you want an appointment make an
appointment i think that's also
really important in treatment with
anybody to have good boundaries but you
do start to see
how hard this is for this character
typically this doesn't happen with ocd
there are other mental health issues
where maybe somebody has really bad
boundaries
i think that's what they're hinting at
too that he has other personality traits
that make it hard for him to interact
with people in his world but at the same
time you see how much pain he's in
if you take responsibility to keep
breaking
the room around two years ago
i also regrew my beard but you're not
interested in changes in niche
that's not typical for someone with ocd
that they don't have any interest
in other people i think what they're
getting at here
is that there's something about this
character that's beyond ocd
that could be a personality disorder
there's a difference between
obsessive-compulsive disorder and
obsessive-compulsive
personality disorder ocd the phrase is
you're uncomfortable you're really
uncomfortable with what's going on
ocpd obsessive-compulsive disorder the
phrase is
you make other people uncomfortable
because you want things
in a certain way and you believe it
should be in a certain way not because
of ocd
just because of the way you're wired
here they're mixing a little bit of both
next up girl interrupted am i in trouble
for kissing an orderly or giving my
boyfriend a
job susannah is supposed to have
a diagnosis of borderline personality
disorder what that means is
somebody's interacting with the world
vastly different than the cultural norm
and it causes problems for them
borderline was originally used to
describe someone who's on the border
between neurotic
meaning managing a lot of anxiety and
psychotic having a break from reality
you have some very interesting theories
about your illness
you believe there is a mystical undertow
in life
quick sense of shadows
we see a couple things that suggest she
does have borderline personality
disorder
you have references to reckless behavior
which can occur
and they're hinting that it's the sexual
episode she's had there
is this description of quicksands of
time which might be more philosophical
but the idea of shadows is she
seeing things at times does she feel
like there's something else there
there can be chronic feelings of
emptiness there can be an
unstable sense of oneself that's what's
being identified here by the
psychiatrist
your progress has plateaued does that
disappoint you
i'm ambivalent in fact that's my new
favorite word
this is actually really good therapy the
psychiatrist identifies a plateau
and she feels this patient can handle it
and pushes her a bit to say
you know what what do you think about
your treatment
it means i don't care that's what it
means on the contrary
susanna ambivalence suggests
strong feelings in opposition she says
she's ambivalent and she's
really identifying something i see in a
lot of patients there are two types of
feeling there's both a desire to get
better
and there's this desire to give up a lot
of times those are the opposing feelings
so you really do see ambivalence in
patients and identifying it is very
important for the therapy
the prefix as in ambidextrous
means both the rest of it in latin
means figure the word suggests that you
are torn
the doctor does a great job in pointing
out that it's not about not caring it's
about the
conflict between really wanting to get
better and feeling like this is so hard
i'm never going to get better and i
can't do this
ambivalence isn't a diagnosis but it's
commented on
it certainly can be commented on and it
is fodder for the therapy i mean that's
certainly something to talk about and
she picks up on it well
i signed myself in i should be able to
sign myself out you signed yourself into
our care we decide when you leave
you can sign yourself involuntarily and
you can
argue that it's time to leave the
hospital they can't keep you like this
unless and you're staging itself danger
to others or you're gravely disabled
how much will you indulge in your flaws
what are your flaws are they flaws
if you embrace them will you commit
yourself to hospital
for life you typically don't have this
kind of intensive psychotherapy when
someone
is in the hospital for a short time this
was a different time
the 60s and this psychiatrist does a
really good job she's actually bringing
forth all the questions that someone
with the borderline personality disorder
might be facing but not know how to
articulate they're wondering are they
really a bad person
that unstable sense of self or are they
not are there different ways to see
things
if i go down this path of thinking about
myself how will my life look if i go
down this path how will life be so she
does a really good job articulating for
the patient
what might be inside her what she might
be thinking what she might be feeling
and that can be a really effective
therapeutic method
there are a lot more pressures on kids
and adolescents these days what used to
happen is if you were getting bullied at
school you were having a disagreement
with somebody
you could go home and have a respite at
least for you know 10 hours 12 hours
now you can't it's non-stop there is
social media there are
text messages that it's just non-stop
not only in a negative way because maybe
people are
cyber bullying but also kids today feel
like their social life
revolves around who's commenting on this
and who's done what so
there's this drive to be social that way
to keep up
and that can cause a lot of anxiety
another good thing that girl interrupted
does is it shows
someone who can participate in their
treatment and who's not
quote-unquote crazy a lot of depictions
of mental illness
show people who are so affected by their
illness that they can't
function in society susannah here does
not have psychotic
illnesses she might have some beliefs
about herself that aren't true but that
could come from trauma it could come
from other things
so girl interrupted does a good job of
showing that you can have somebody who
is quite functional
for many people mental illness is a part
of who they are it doesn't define them
next up inside out wouldn't it be great
to be back out on the ice
oh yeah that sounds fantastic
it's a pretty good depiction of
depression in a teenager
people often expect kids and teenagers
to appear sad when they're depressed but
more commonly you see teenagers as
irritable
there is literally the absence of joy in
her mind
and she's not necessarily sad she's
irritable
she doesn't know what to do or what to
say that might be polite because she's
not focused on that
did you guys pick up on that uh-huh
something's wrong should we ask her
let's probe but keep it subtle so she
doesn't notice
so how was the first day of school she's
probing
us the other part of this that's really
good is the depiction of the parents
while humorous
the mom's wondering what do i do what do
i do for
my daughter something's not quite right
they have a sense that something's not
okay
i think it's pretty clear as you see her
more throughout the movie that she's
suffering from some depression
in depression you look for a depressed
mood or
that irritability in an adolescent you
look at loss of appetite
difficulty with sleep are the things
that interested her still
joyful to her so hockey used to be it
doesn't seem to be anymore
how she's concentrating she's not even
focused on the questions it's kind of
huh what
you look at all of these things and
together they describe a picture of
depression
kids feel a lot of different things and
especially in the teenage years
what they're interested in is new to
them they don't know how to
explore that sometimes so all these
feelings do intermix and do
exist in the head of a teenager i'm
somebody who doesn't believe that
teenage years need to be all kinds of
crazy
i think actually they can be enjoyable
years but it's important for parents
to let kids explore life and to
take chances school was great all right
riley is everything okay
sir she just rolled her eyes at us what
is her deal
riley also just moved from minnesota to
san francisco which is like moving to
the moon
so it's totally understandable that she
would feel out of place
even little things are hard for her to
get used to when i see kids one of the
things i ask are there any major life
changes because it can really be
jarring to somebody riley i do not like
this new attitude oh i'll show you
attitude
no no no no stay happy what is your
problem just leave me alone
it is common for kids and teenagers
though to have mood issues to have
depression to have anxiety and in some
areas the bay area for instance
new york is a high pressure so you often
see kids with a lot of anxiety
that's it go to your room now
good job gentlemen that could have been
a disaster
well that was a disaster with
adolescence there are certain approaches
that i
recommend parents take you learn a lot
more from an adolescent when you are
sitting
side by side with them or walking side
by side with them as opposed to direct
eye contact
that's more threatening for a teenager
so if you go to a baseball game
or if you're driving or walking you're
going to get a lot more out of that
teenager than you would if you're
sitting there
talking them eye to eye also probing is
a good word you don't have to probe
the teenager you can make observations
you can make
quick observations that can be really
helpful for fostering conversation
this movie is actually really supposed
to be about mental health they had
consultants
working on the film psychologists and
people who really did explore emotions
they really wanted to get it
to be an accurate depiction of mental
health issues so i really like this
movie and i think they did a good job
depicting that
and also the parents feel so helpless
and they just want their kid to feel
good
and that's a message i see all the time
from parents
next up lars and the real girl midwest
living
or country home
that's what i would say first thought
you'd have about this guy is that he's
psychotic he has some delusional
thinking here
meaning he believes this doll is real
despite evidence to show
she's not real in real life you'd never
see a psychotic
issue like this because this lasts
through the whole movie
and psychosis is generally not that
persistent
when someone has a psychotic disorder
you'd have episodes of that
lars in the movie is being depicted as
somebody who
really has no interest in relationships
he's wearing gloves at times too doesn't
want to touch people
so it's never really explained in the
movie what lars has
but when i look at him i think he has
some form of autism
probably what would have been called
asperger's we don't use the term
asperger's disorder any longer
what used to be those criteria are now
fit under
autistic spectrum disorder he can
communicate with people
but he has trouble with relationships he
doesn't know how to have them
and that can be part of the problem in
terms of how they socialize and
communicate with other people
the fact that he does want to have it
makes me think he falls more in line
with
an autistic spectrum disorder as opposed
to
other psychiatric illnesses that you
might see where someone stays away from
other people and fails to have
relationships with them
one of those things is schizoid
personality disorder where a person
doesn't want to have any contact with
anybody they
see no meaning whatsoever in
relationships he seems to see
something because he wants to have this
relationship with bianca he brings her
to the doctor
and is concerned about her blood
pressure and i really think the best way
to think about lars is what's the poetic
meaning behind
it but if we're looking for a mental
health diagnosis it probably falls more
in line with autistic spectrum disorder
i want you to bring her in every week
for special treatment
can you do that
yeah are you sure that that's necessary
i like to look at the whole emotional
picture of lars that's certainly what
the doctor here does
what lars does have trouble with is
interacting with other people
at times he's seen wearing black gloves
even he doesn't want to touch people
said it hurts if you look at the
psychological
way to interpret that the emotional part
of it he had a mother who died early
to the point that his father wasn't
available to him that's some significant
psychological trauma for a kid not to
have parents who are emotionally
available
so wearing those gloves might signify
it's painful for him to even imagine
being able to touch somebody because he
feels so removed and so isolated from
people
so there's a real emotional meaning
behind this movie and the doctor picks
up on it
i look forward to getting to know you
bianca so
this doctor is also a psychologist in
the movie
in this case she's recognizing that this
doll means
something to lars it's not just a
psychotic disorder which means it's not
just
some delusion there's something here
more emotional for him
and she picks up on that she asks him to
come back and she's starting to
some might say play into the delusion
but i think what she's doing
she's creating what's called a holding
space what that is
in psychology is a place for someone to
make a transition from something
very difficult emotionally to another
place that can be also difficult
emotionally
i think for lars he's transitioning from
not really knowing how to have
relationships with people
to even trying and this doll is kind of
the object that he starts to use to make
that transition
it's a good thing this is in wisconsin
because good luck getting somebody to
buy into this in new york city
but in this town this doctor can foster
the whole town the inquire about bianca
and make it seem like she is real
because she sees it is something
important to lars
i think again this is more of a magical
movie in that sense
there is that emotional component to it
if you are a functioning
person in therapy coming every week
there could be
some therapeutic component to talking
about the doll
he's not hurting anybody with the doll
he's not causing any violence he's not
doing anything that would make it seem
like he's not functioning or needs to go
to hospital
so this is certainly a path to try to
understand him more
next up silver linings playbook
mom i can't find my wedding video mom
wake up what is it where's my wedding
video it's
after three o'clock what are you doing i
looked in here but this is all you're
up here for your sewing and everything
this is a good depiction of a manic
episode
a manic episode means that for about a
week
someone has had increased energy with no
need for a full night's sleep maybe just
a couple hours
they can be really elevated with their
mood and they can be irritable
there's also a grandiosity a sense of
self-importance
possibly even doing things that are
somewhat dangerous or reckless and we're
seeing
him start to spiral into this manic
episode here
we know the character has a bipolar
disorder bipolar disorder
means that there's this change in mood
from baseline to this expansive
elevated state there can be the other
side a depressive episode but it doesn't
have to be for somebody to be diagnosed
with a bipolar disorder some people with
bipolar disorder
have only a manic state every now and
then they don't have the depressive
low you can get something in a manic
episode called increased
goal-directed behavior you can be really
focused on one thing some people it's
like i'm going to write the next great
novel i'm going to change the course of
humanity
i'm going to rebuild this wing of my
home this is a much
smaller task but he does get very
focused on finding this wedding video
it's not unheard of to have a task that
doesn't seem to mean a lot
suddenly take up all of someone's time
when they're in the middle of a manic
episode
hey it's my wedding it's my wedding
video
what's also important to note is that
their family
are woken up in the middle of the night
the family involvement is quite often
seen a family can get really disrupted
because of an untreated episode or
because of these episodes
you have to make some hard choices if
this were going on and he's manic like
this and he were actually
violent with the family and not able to
stop he might have to call the police
and have him
brought in to a mental health hospital
so that he can be at least evaluated for
some time and calm down
he's a cop what are you doing it's a
medication problem yeah
he's fine he's fine now you want to send
him back to baltimore the mother
says it's a medication issue it can be
really demeaning to
a patient to feel like everything's
dismissed and it's just about medication
it's true that that often is said and
it's really painful to the person who
has the bipolar disorder or any mental
health
issue it's common with mental illness
that people do have strong feelings
about their medication
there can be side effects in a bipolar
disorder if it's a manic episode you
would try to put the brakes on with an
anti-psychotic medication and those
medications do have side effects they
can make people very sleepy
there can be weight gain but it's a
bigger danger to have somebody who's
manic
who can do dangerous things you can use
some medications including
antipsychotics
as mood stabilizers for long-term
treatment family members can really
support people with bipolar disorder or
even other mental health issues
in many ways or you can ask them what's
it like to have this they might not want
to talk about it but just
saying something like if you ever want
to talk about this i'm certainly willing
to talk about it with you i want to be
here to help you
so just knowing that somebody's there
for you to talk about can be
super helpful support and love are very
important when it comes to
helping somebody with mental illness it
can't cure it that's the knock on the
movie is that
everything turns out fine and there's
some hint that pat starts taking his
medication again but
it's a hint it's not something that's
shown very clearly so you
do need to have love you do need to have
support but it's not going to clear
everything
next up a beautiful mind saw my name on
the lecture sleeve
who are you talking to tell me who you
see here we see
a depiction of schizophrenia and
schizophrenia is often misunderstood
schizophrenia is a psychotic illness
it's an illness meaning there's a break
from reality
schizophrenia is the diagnosis you give
after seeing someone have a consistent
psychotic
episode or episodes over a certain
amount of time
so at first it would be a psychotic
episode or a psychotic
break but you wait to diagnose
schizophrenia until
time has passed and it's still there a
month long
of hallucinations or delusions or
thought disorder
in schizophrenia visual hallucinations
are not as consistent
as this guy charles his so-called
roommate i think they're trying to
obviously get you to see that
he's seeing something that's not really
there but you don't usually see
something as consistent it's more of a
blur it's more temporary the doctor
really does try to ask john what's going
on what are you seeing and that's a good
technique what i often like to do is say
something like
do you feel like your mind is playing
tricks on you do you feel like you're
seeing things other people aren't seeing
or hearing things other people aren't
hearing
sometimes that can be a little bit more
gentle than what are you seeing but i
think
it is a good idea to figure out what is
this person seeing
there's no one there john there's no one
it's right there
some of these medications do have side
effects that can include drooling
but it shouldn't be a deterrent from
taking medication
because the medications can help with
delusions and hallucinations that really
impair someone's ability to function
one thing that a beautiful mind did was
it kind of correlated having
schizophrenia and having a psychotic
illness with having genius or that he's
a genius because of his schizophrenia
that's not the case you're not going to
become a genius because you have
a psychotic illness like schizophrenia
he might have a high
intellect and also have schizophrenia
but it's not the cause
of it in fact there's what's called a
downward drift
if someone has a psychotic illness and
doesn't get treated
over time it becomes harder and harder
for them to function in society not that
they get smarter and smarter
and they actually have a really hard
time functioning in their daily life
my name is john nash i'm being held
against my will
somebody call the department of defense
you do sometimes see
patients yelling out like that who are
delusional or are paranoid that they're
being held against their will and
sometimes they are being held against
their will because they're believed to
be a danger to themselves or others or
because they actually can't provide
themselves with food clothing and
shelter they're gravely disabled which
is more of what
he is but you do see people sometimes
yell like this
this is an old psych ward it's pretty
big and there are a lot of people around
i think in this shot here there's maybe
six mental health providers i feel like
in some states there might not even be
six mental health providers there's such
a shortage of mental health providers
but a psychiatric ward can look like
this
where there are rooms and those rooms
are private rooms for people this is
dramatized to some degree they usually
don't look like jails so that part's a
little bit off
but i can see that they're trying to
show that the patients are housed here
in their individual rooms and doors on
the left
i think it's really important for media
to get depictions of mental health right
because people get a lot of their
information from these
movies even though it's not necessarily
accurate
it's important to be accurate i was at a
convention once this girl stood up
started crying and said when am i going
to see a depiction of someone with
mental illness who's not going to make
me feel like i'm going to turn into a
serial killer
so that's reason enough to have accurate
depictions so people don't
feel shamed about themselves so people
don't feel ashamed to go into treatment
so people can have conversations and
people can really pursue the help that
they need
thanks so much for watching these clips
with me i enjoyed breaking them down and
i hope you did too
hope to do it again with you in the
future
[Music]